yeah if I don't talk about this I
officially lose my right to do videos
like forever so it's officially been
announced today the villains that will
be in the Dark Knight Rises and the
actors who will play them and we all
already knew that Tom Hardy was going to
be a villain but no one knew who's gonna
play like people thought Hugo Strange
what not it's officially been released
today that he's actually going to be
Bane I couldn't have called that not
gonna lie not in a million years because
people should think obeying the guy who
beaten broke Batman that's awesome that
should happen but people think oh the
guy from that shitty movie so it looks
like Nolan's taking it back and
Christopher Nolan had said that the
movies going to be like this
technological marvel and I'm pretty sure
Bane's the reason why a lot of CGI
involved I imagine and the next villain
will be Selina Kyle or Catwoman played
by Anne Hathaway which is fine for me
because one Anne Hathaway is just really
hot and yet a great actress you know and
respectable and all that she's hot know
right now we just know that she's gonna
play Selina Kyle so it might be that
whole Harvey Dent thing where Harvey
Dent became two-face at the end of The
Dark Knight
might be a spoiler to say that to some
people but if it's a spoiler where have
you been so right now she's Selina Kyle
she's Catwoman which is also great
because I thought when people thought
Catwoman they thought oh great that
shitty movie so it looks like in both
cases Christopher Nolan's taking the
characters back for us like you know us
fans who thought that their characters
died in those shitty movies because one
Bane is not like boom he's really smart
and in the Dark Knight Rises I'm pretty
sure they're gonna make him that way
they're gonna make him what he should be
the guy who could break Batman [ __ ]
maybe he will break Batman and I'm
really excited to see how they do
Catwoman that's a really cool dynamic
that I want to see in a Nolan movie you
know romantic interest / alter-ego
villain how can you pass that up so
officially from Warner Brothers Tom
Hardy is bane and Anne Hathaway is
Catwoman / Selina Kyle I'm pumped I want
to see how they do these characters and
I want to see Nolan do them right so as
always what do you guys think about this
comment below blow that [ __ ] up official
Batman villains for The Dark Knight
Rises let's talk about it and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more